so I saw this viral video of some kid
and he's like I live with my parents and
my girlfriend because I can't afford
rent because to even get some place to
live like a studio or one bedroom was
like a thousand bucks per person that's
insane how can anyone afford that right
make sure that people can't afford to
live and you guarantee yourself a
revolution so
maybe that's why they're building
bunkers in New Zealand because they're
preparing for something that uh I guess
we can all see coming and probably
should prepare for too I mean I don't
want to talk about the possibility of
like crazy International globalists
creating nuclear war to kill off a bunch
say anything about that I I'm talking
about economic crisis in which you get
socialism and so they have ranches in
New Zealand